wherever he chooses to appear this
academy-award-winning after his
pronounced star in any language
presenting mr. Jeremy Irons
whenever I sit down in front of a
foreign language film I get a thrill as
the first subtitle appears for I know
I'm about to be transported into lives
far from my own yet by the closing
titles I'm always amazed that though our
language may be different our desires
our needs and aspirations are the same
this year's nominees for foreign
language films come to America from
Belgium Cuba Russia Taiwan and from the
republic of macedonia the country the
filmmakers call Macedonia and the UN
calls the Former Yugoslav Republic of
Macedonia introvert is not the standing
all these films are stunning reminders
that we are fast becoming one world
watching their cinematic art it's
impossible to ignore our universal
humanity love and hatred tenderness and
cruelty laughter and tears from that
rich palette of emotions the Academy has
chosen these nominees for Best Foreign
Language Film of 1994 from Macedonia
before the rain Milko manchester
director
from Russia burned by the Sun Nikita
Mikhalkov
director from Taiwan eat drink man woman
and li the rapture from Belgium
farinelli ill castrato Gerard cuvee Oh
director from Cuba strawberry and
chocolate
Thomas Gutierrez Alea and Juan Carlos de
bo directors and the Oscar goes to
Russia combatants by the Sun accepting
the award for director Nikita Mikhalkov
oh I'm sure I didn't speak English
never speak English on this stage
I want to thank all my friends who
worked with me my script writer was Tom
Regan bakov great composer eduard
artemiev my co-producer vladimir sidorov
nicole can and all my friends who worked
with me and you know mashallah Mastriani
said in fellini's film great great film
eight and a half I want to say the truth
which I don't know but which which I
tried to find me - I want to try I want
to say I the truth which I don't know
and maybe I want to say the truth cruel
truth but I'm absolutely sure that the
cruel truth without love is a lie and
my daughter she's my actress and first
time in my life I didn't have problem
with actress